CBS News chief Washington correspondent
major Garrett is with us at the table
major good morning the person we want to
see you like this
president Trump is a it takes a position
of no apologies no regrets and he's
trying to redirect attention to the
comments the squad has made over their
short tenure they are also saying no
regrets is that strategy going to work
for them as it has it seemed for the
president well in that interview and I
think they would say on behalf of
themselves if you apologize to someone
who never apologizes you're engaging in
rhetorical disarmament and they're not
going to do that in the age of Trump
apologizing does not advance any issue
or the argument you basically back away
your supporters don't want you to
apologize I want you to do that either
so that is one dimension of this the
larger question is are they being
successful in a sort of way for his
first year lawmakers unquestionably they
have a national platform Joe Biden talks
about them Nancy Pelosi the Speaker of
the House worries about them or at least
concerned about their activism they have
risen because of social media to a level
of influence and dialogue almost unheard
of for a first year lawmaker and this is
something I've had to get used to I
think the speaker probably is as well
though in different ways when I first
started covering Congress in 1990 you
did things accomplish things to become
known that paradigm is completely
shifted now you become known to better
accomplish things and that is what's
playing out before our very eyes they
were very good the president is the one
that seems intent on making them as
well-known as possible it seems that
maybe a 2020 strategy yes read his
tweets this is not a person on politics
who acts subtly or with new on job his
tweet this is a very calculated move he
has said they are now the face and the
soul of the Democratic Party part of
what he said in motion this weekend he
hoped would be to force Democrats to
circle the wagons around these four and
say you see the Democratic Party is
either socialist radical yep the newest
implication communist all these things
built to do one thing for 2020 what's
that fill the vacuum left by Hillary
Clinton yeah Hillary Clinton was a very
easy target for all Republicans to
instantly almost inflexibly rally around
and thought it won't be there in 2020 so
is that or what is that
the president's trying to create that
now say you know I I didn't I wasn't
quite sure what to expect because you
hear all the chatter but they I felt
we're very impressive they're very
committed they're very passionate and
when you sit and take the time to really
talk and listen to them cuz I thought
you know shouldn't you just sort of get
the lay of the land and see how it works
around here first
that is not how they're operating they
are very committed to making change that
they think is better for the
constituents who elected them who
elected them now they are not in the
majority within the Democratic colony or
not they're fighters they're pushing
pushing pushing one of the things they
said in the interview is for now the
fight is the victory pressing ahead and
not giving up is what they want to do I
would say this President Trump says that
all the time
believe it what you believe in you never
give up yeah on that Paris they agree
and they're being heard yes say all
right Thank You major